donald trump
is now apparently turning not only on
fox news but also on newsmax donald
trump appeared on newsmax last night
and he said the election is stolen
and fox news no longer talks about it
and newsmax no longer talks about it he
says i guess that they're afraid
and he even says to the newsmax host i
bet you guys are going to cut what i'm
saying right now and the host says no no
no we're not going to cut it check this
out trump's furious with anyone who
won't uncritically repeat his baseless
and false claims check this out look at
the dishonesty of this committee right
they don't talk about any of the things
that refute january 6. they don't talk
about the election numbers they don't
analyze the election the people were
there because the election was rigged
and stolen
so what they should be doing is trying
to convince people that it wasn't you do
that through analyzing the numbers they
don't want to do that in fact they don't
even want to hear that
and fox doesn't put it on and by the way
you people don't put it on either you're
afraid of being sued or something i
don't know someday you'll have to
explain that this is yeah well at a
certain point you can only lie so much
before you're potentially in legal
jeopardy that's true it is everything
trump is saying isn't true uh in fact
they'll probably cut what i'm saying of
course now i don't know of course this
will be on wake up don't let tomorrow
morning sir absolutely not get it done
get it done fast before chris sees it
okay
but
might cut it out and let's just see i
hope they put it on yeah but this was
about a rigged and stolen election now
that's not actually what the committee
is about
understand it's when trump says
the committee won't investigate this
other thing it's sort of like saying
this committee refuses to talk about
the rash of thefts of catalytic
converters from priuses well okay
the the that's not the focus of the
committee
the thefts of catalytic converters also
happen to happens to be a real thing
whereas the uh theft of the election is
imaginary but it's not what the
committee is there to do that millions
and millions of people felt is true
right and of course facts don't care
about your feelings but trump continues
to repeat
people feel the election was stolen
people feel it was stolen and fox news
no longer talks about it and newsmax no
longer talks about it they talked about
it for months they talk about it for
months and there's nothing there now
what trump is really saying when he says
this is
media outlets that are supposed to be
friendly to me aren't doing enough heavy
lifting on the lies that i am trying to
perpetuate
that's the translation for what trump is
saying here
interestingly trump was also asked
during this interview about the
allegations made by cassidy hutchinson
that he lunged at a secret service agent
um and tried to commandeer the vehicle
trump's explanation for why it's not
true
is sort of that he's too fat to do the
thing he was accused of doing listen
carefully here and they put her on and
they don't even confirm it with the
secret service the secret service people
in the car
said this didn't happen but but you
don't even need that now remember
they have not testified under oath there
is a report
through the grapevine that some secret
service agent is willing to contradict
some of what cassidy hutchinson said
none of it has actually happened yet but
okay let's continue who would do that i
would i would grab a secret service
person by the throat i don't even know
if it's possible certainly not in the
beast it's very hard even in one of the
suvs it's very hard for another reason
these guys lift 350 pounds right right
so when trump says these guys lift 350
pounds and i don't what he's saying is
he's out of shape what he's saying is
he's obese what he's saying is it would
be a stupid thing to do
to try to do anything but trump does
stupid things all the time narcissists
overstate their or over
they over believe they are falsely
confident in all of their abilities not
only their intelligence but maybe also
their physical abilities and by the way
notice that what was said there the
beast versus suvs initially the claim
was in the beast meaning the
presidential limo trump is sitting so
far from the driver that he couldn't do
the thing cassidy hutchinson accused him
of doing but when you look at the video
of that day if i recall correctly trump
is actually leaving in an suv it's a
different vehicle completely so when
laura ingram and others say you can't do
that in the limo
the video seems to show trump in an suv
all right let's look at the last bit of
this v tonight it seemed like it was
pretty smooth yeah i know like
it's fine i mean like but you know these
are
people these are great people these are
great people they've devoted their lives
to it and i think they were very
embarrassed by it because it makes them
sound terrible tony ornato and bobby
engel uh
they are sterling
and it was very nice that they came to
my defense i thought it was incredible
actually now remember
there are allegations that they would
come to trump's defense they have not
actually done it yet in any kind of
significant way because
you know some whack job can say this
stuff and get away with it and other
things that i wanted guns at my rally
okay now i'm speaking why would i want
guns i don't want people having standing
with guns in my rally oh so guns are
dangerous now wow okay i mean if he
believes guns everywhere make everybody
safer why wouldn't he want the gun it's
all a verbal inkblot test but trump now
upset with fox that they won't do his
carry water on his election lies upset
that newsmax won't even though they kind
of do but just not to that degree and
trump essentially saying i'm not in
shape enough to do the thing that i was
accused of doing
make of it what you will we'll have
these clips on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack offering delicious sweet granola
bars and nut and seed bars with only one
gram of sugar or less two to three net
carbs perfect if you do keto and 150
calories or under so you can enjoy a
sweet satisfying crunchy snack without
the guilt their granola bars come in
flavors like peanut butter coconut cocoa
chip honey nut my favorite blueberry
almond vanilla
monk pack nut and seed bars come in
flavors like sea salt dark chocolate
macadamia white chocolate caramel sea
salt and pumpkin seed cinnamon i've
always found the flavor and texture of
these bars awesome and unique you've got
to try it at least once i think you'll
be hooked and if you don't love monk
pack as much as i do they'll refund all
of your money or exchange the product
you'll also get twenty percent off your
first order when you go to monkpack.com
and enter the code pacman at checkout or
click the link in the description